welcome to this video playing rough
who's roughed nope no name okay so maybe
I can avoid the names of form one time
what do we get Pusha precincts
completely an theoretical move so can I
win the bar now this is the same thing
as no way I can win the porn right I
cannot win a born tell me
what is he doing yeah that's a really
strange opening so I'm grabbing
hmm that's really what what cat okay
with that okay and you just continuous
like nothing happened okay yeah shall I
even upload this stuff yeah maybe for
what is this God can't continue it cheap
I cannot pronounce that word check check
check mate if it's really in Russia
that's bit early to drink it's about
noon here and in Germany and yeah bishop
this success but we had already but yeah
well you have to go see six or something
maybe we should be seven-pointed giving
a temple this is really a boobs it's
just just a pawn I mean there is this
common kettrick hear it i've got 92 so
that's not working at all yeah spearmint
it's already winning at any when tre
this is so completely crazy maybe you
get a good laugh out of it thanks for
watching